where I tend to battle with people is
they think it's either infinite or
finite and they defend finite and the
whole point of infinite minded thinking
is you can absolutely have finite games
in an infinite game just like I can try
and be healthy and still set a goal of
how much weight I want to lose I can
still have goals and numbers I metrics
are very important human beings are
tangible animals we we need to see the
numbers to make us feel like we're
making progress but there has to be a
context why are we counting these things
it can't just be growth for growth sake
or to make me Rich or you know to hit
some arbitrary goal and some arbitrary
date what is the point of growth what is
the point of hitting those numbers it
has to contribute to something bigger so
yeah the biggest arguments are really
The finite-minded Defenders to be quite
honest